on every high street these days families
are making tough choices about what they
can afford but while energy bills are
about to soar to new heights politicians
and business leaders say the government
is in paralysis the prime minister could
gather the candidates to ensure that on
august 26th when we hear what the price
rise is going to be there's a common
pledge a cost of living pledge from the
prime minister
liz truss and rishi sunak to say they
will indeed stand behind houses and
households as they face rising energy
bills the cost of living payments
announced by the treasury will continue
to be rolled out over the coming months
but with fuel bills forecast to hit well
over three thousand pounds this autumn
millions more people could be plunged
into fuel poverty it's boris johnson's
first day back from holiday and the
chancellor over at number 11 has been
away too
and when asked whether it was all hands
on deck to give people further support
the prime minister's spokesman said no
the convention is that decisions on
further measures will be for his
successor
the leadership contenders have
distinctly different plans liz trusts
prioritizing tax cuts but not ruling out
going further
rishi sunak's team say today that he
would guarantee targeted support to the
most vulnerable
these residents in slough are already
feeling the pinch
nobody knows where they're gonna get the
money from
no the wages is still
though you have your plan like okay i'm
gonna spend this much money on my bills
but then the bills go higher so now you
have to cut other things out so it's a
bit of a glitch i don't know what the
government's gonna do to help us but
don't see any hope it's not my problem
anymore it's the next one and then it's
this difficulty with the next leadership
dealing with the problems of the
previous one so i think there just needs
to be a leadership that just doesn't run
away after you know a difficult you know
difficult challenges good morning a
former prime minister says the crisis
cannot wait until the autumn every other
country there is a recognition of this
crisis and people are acting now and
it's time for this government no matter
what's happening in the tory leadership
contest they should all get together and
see if they can agree on a program but
it's got to happen in the next few days
scottish first minister nicola sturgeon
has written asking boris johnson to
bring forward an emergency meeting with
devolved governments before households
she says are unable to feed themselves
or heat their homes
at the end of august the new price cap
for the winter months will be announced
the prime minister and his would-be
successors are on notice that they don't
have weeks or months to find solutions
tomorrow cohen sky news westminster